what's happening with the trans thing
that we i that we all seemingly have to
bow down to this that if you do not
accept that four-year-olds who feel a
different way a boy who feels a little
bit like a girl should be on puberty
blockers and on their way to becoming
the other gender if you don't buy into
all of that that you're somehow a bigot
or mean or anything else well all of
this nonsense it's leaking into our
military and this video came out
yesterday we're going to show you a
couple clips of it this is absolutely
insane
this is from the u.s navy i am not
kidding you you're going to be watching
this in a second from now and you're
going to go dave that can't be real this
seems like amateur hour from a high
school
but this is the u.s navy
training its staff
to create a safe space
by using gender pronouns
take a look
hi my name is johnny and i use he him
pronouns hi and i am kanji and i use chi
her pronouns and we're here to talk
about pronouns
what is a pronoun a pronoun is how we
identify ourselves apart from our name
and it's also how people refer to us in
conversations using the right pronouns
is a really simple way to affirm
someone's identity it is a signal of
acceptance and respect instead of saying
something like hey guys you can say hey
everyone or hey team
yeah and now that you say that another
way that we could show that we're allies
and that we accept
everybody is to maybe include our
pronouns in our emails or like we just
did introduce ourselves using our
pronouns
oh there's more coming people and that's
real i know you're watching it you're
going that can't be real dave today is
not april fool's day don't punk us like
that but that is real that is a real
video that the u.s navy put out who are
those two people they don't even seem
like real people they seem like
automatons what is her accent it seems
like it's robotic and they're saying
things that have nothing to do with the
navy didn't the navy have something to
do with a bunch of guys getting in the
water and then going to save people
perhaps or we blow up something or
we got more i'm going to stay on screen
for this one because this is so insane
here we go and another tip
for you to remember their
pronoun next time it's in your mind kind
of go through a progression of three
good things about the person using their
pronouns so let's say the person
chooses to use day
then you will in your mind go
they have a nice shirt
they have a nice smile they are really
smart so that kind of sticks in your
brain that is
listen
i gotta warn you people
there is collective brain damage
happening across the world right now
okay it's happening right in front of
our faces imagine imagine you're in the
navy imagine you come from a proud navy
family
right
i've been to annapolis where the naval
academy is i was at the naval academy
about a year ago took a walk around it's
really lovely place i imagine you come
from a proud naval family
and they are subjecting you to that
sheer drivel not not only is it complete
insanity it's just complete insanity
that has nothing to do with nothing it
has
nothing certainly nothing to do with the
navy being effective at what your job is
protecting this country making sure that
if a pirate ship is attacking another
ship that you're going to take care of
the other ship
it continues to share something with you
that happened uh the other day at akuka
i was at we were talking about pronouns
and somebody was disagreeing with
how different people
see themselves as different pronouns and
the argument was if you look like a
female then it's chi her because that's
what's normal and if you make me call
you something else then you're
infringing on my rights and i i was
really taken aback by the comment and i
really wasn't sure
how to respond and the only thing i
could really think quickly to say was
it's not about you at all
and
it's mostly and ultimately about respect
but if i were to tell you over and over
again my name is johnny
and you insist on mispronouncing my name
i would feel disrespected by you
some names are very difficult to
pronounce but do you know what is very
easy to pronounce
she he they
[Music]
let's be clear about something let's be
clear that's what joe biden says all the
time let's be clear she he them are
[ __ ] bananas those people are insane
you don't have to behave the way these
people want they're not real human
beings and what i mean by that is they
have no understanding of what it is to
get and earn respect and to be an adult
in a world that doesn't have to bow to
you a world that exists and then you do
your best within that world the fact
that this has leaked into our military
is so nuts